all right and we are live happy 2019 and
welcome to the iron Lords podcast
episode number 93 and it's another
glorious Sunday and we have back at the
roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
extremely excited about our special
guests and we've got Microsoft next
generation approach the state of
Activision Blizzard and the mad box
console to discuss so we gonna get right
into it I want to introduce two Lords
who not only raised the ball with
extremely high quality content and in
both of their respective genres but also
provide one of the most unique podcast
experiences combining outstanding online
journalism in addition to extremely
informative yet balanced perspective in
all of YouTube introducing the dynamic
duo and co-host of the Xbox two podcast
the one Lord who demands crafting and
survival mechanics and every genre of
gaming the other Lord whose addiction to
pub G chicken dinners will one day
surpasses billion gamers cope Germany
and shout out have arrived and for the
first time making their debut into the
realm of the Lords together the man with
the million Lord ran down Thor and
Windows central Lords jazz Gordon how
are you doing xbox - you're so good at
intros you definitely could teach me
something I listened to Cognito and I'm
just not that good dude you know you've
got a down pat I like the way the poor
man's pleasure Lords in your respective
realms here had to show you the proper
respect man how you two dudes doing like
it's just good to have both of you at
how both you doing I mean I go first I
love this podcast it's one of my
favorites thank you said I've been
waiting for you to come and be like
random yjo on again
and then to find out that my co-host
whoa-ho host with the most jazz was
gonna be on to him like what yes great
cuz mean Jess haven't we haven't podcast
stood since what Christmas there before
Christmas yes schedules have been too
hectic so we know is you know just as
busy person to get nailed down sometimes
right you know he's very important you
talk to hit me up like I can't do it
today and I got an interview I'm
conducting with Phil Spencer and I'm
like it's cool it's cool cold work for
Jess has gotten Hollywood I don't know
[Laughter]
[Music]
how you doing there but I guess I owe
you a hard man to nail down sometimes as
a red said but uh how you do I'm good
man sometimes are pretty good for me
last week was crazy because you know
it's a new yeah all the meetings about
content strategy changes hires and all
that sort of stuff hired more gaming
staff planning to grow the side this
year nice interesting plans in that
respect okay for that nice relaxing
gaming weekend nice that's good to hear
there and full disclosure the Xbox two
is one of my very favorite podcast
listen you guys what I do a lot of long
drives and I love the banter love the
energy to or the best of the game in and
we go have some fun today are you ready
yes I am ready let's do it man and you
know we have the Four Horsemen of gaming
those original orders around here at the
roundtable my co-hosts with the cold
most my brother from another mother the
difficult game Conqueror and the how of
the young vault mommy
Lord addict are you doing sir doing
pretty good definitely getting to uh
just just as a full disclosure my lazy
bum couldn't figure out a topic so I
picked it it Lord called amido got the
ax talking
you guys are about to hear this because
I was actually reading that this morning
I was like yo this is crazy I figured
you might like if it suited you glad
that you are you adjusting to the new
time sir are you doing with that you
know I probably haven't slept for more
than four hours it's like the more
leeway I get in the better timeframe I'm
like what can I get away you can't give
him leave with what were you plagued
last night to fight over watch to like
almost 3:00 in the morning worse because
I'm G like nobody's business
yesterday I was on oh my god I was I was
gonna play yesterday actually I
downloaded the test server cuz I compare
n't Li the new maps on there or
something mm-hmm like I went through all
the trouble to download it we'll get all
the trouble than John jumps I want to
play overwatch yeah sure let's go play
over a new map is tight man I I really
like that new map and even pub G the ice
sword that is that game godly on this LG
OLED Oh everything so I can see
everything picture-perfect you try to
say that Club clear 4k makes you a
better gamer yes there is
old 4k incredible difference hey I told
you run like it's ridiculous I went from
a 40 inch 4k to a 55 inch LD OLED and I
can see everything on the battlefield
from deep across the map I see dude all
the way over there 330 I wouldn't be
able to be blurry on my TV this thing
it's nice clear bright with the HDR 10 C
thieves is like the best looking game
I've ever seen
edit enjoy
so what question now live in a play
welcome to the premium experience and of
course we have our most technical gaming
Lord the solo gamer who lives for the
single player selfish experience and
also the sashka Damas mister offline
profile Illuminati and Lord patreon of
the iron bank mommy
Lord sovereign how you doing sir chillin
man happy new you everybody that's going
good man ready to go man like rez evil
was like two and a half weeks away dude
three weeks away that's crazy
that is absolutely bananas and two weeks
of getting ready for that res yeah ready
for that man you know what and and
addict addict appreciate this I tried I
watched to break down videos of the
story of Kingdom Hearts to try to give
it a shot woo
you got that story is so complicated you
have to pick the right ones to watch the
video was 30 minutes
I saw the Eurogamer one and I saw one
another one I think was an IGN one and
the Eurogamer one is about a half hour
long dude like you know I get it but I'm
like why why does it need to be this
convoluted there's no it's that they did
wrong ordering when it came to making
the games you know like the very first
one is technically like the third one
like the third one yet and anything
about it is like they don't give you
necessarily the impression that all that
you have to play all of these but you do
if you really want to get this if you
didn't play the very last four for the
3ds the three will make no sense to you
at all know what I mean
[ __ ] abbas was getting this I'll have it
people to understand this fan
thanks man you're going through at the
end of this month like you're gonna be
on top Twitter and be like oh he he like
Kingdom Hearts what the hell so that's
been pretty much it yeah man I haven't
done much gaming especially the last
week and a half
um the first week I was off and I got
back into the spider-man so I did the
first two DLCs I haven't started silver
mining Fonzarelli he was coming at you
MJ Bush incredibly subpar compared to
the main game silver linings is great on
the UM the turf wars was that was soso
but the story arc throughout was very
good I think it's okay to be honest with
you that content if put in the game and
not DLC it wouldn't a really made sense
so the way they put it inside this
shouldn't have broke it up for me the
one thing PL CR but they broke it up to
keep people playing for months on end
it's two hours each one maybe an hour
and a half is yes a nice side mission is
it's not no big deal see like you get
what other games it's just a maximal
side mission pretty good so spider-man
that was it at rapture your holiday
Lords ah yeah that's pretty much it real
quick on the patreon stuff we'll go back
to the patreon stuff next week guys we
have two guests today so I make sure
they get that just do so I was right on
next week no no sounds good sir and of
course we have the Incredible Hulk of
this aka the excess gamer oh the lord of
combat sports was a man of its
convictions demands nothing less than
that premium experience it is the leader
of the fraud alert movement beloved Lord
King how you doing sir I'm incredibly
well right now because I got some sleep
cogito Kobe I was like I'm up don't
worry buddy
at 1 p.m. Eastern it is its scenic
suiting you better
it doesn't matter cup noodles a
worrywart I've noticed in the chat he
put it up at 12:12 alright so for you
frogs out there ohoho getting it I am
sick and tired of this red vs. blue crap
I'm gonna tell you right now if you want
my friends listen you don't want to get
blocked deleted push back into the
bushes stop adding the internet the
siren is out earlier tonight
PlayStation vs Xbox hear like you read
this it's ignorant to the point is broke
vs. rich
that's what is actually an uproar I've
realized it when you have everything it
is obey over there no I got it so I'm
over there with them so when you can't
afford something then you try to defend
your choice as you watch your choice
winner Thanks yeah what I would say is
take all that energy right go mow
somebody's lawn so you can get enough
money I don't hate the system
this is 2019 you can't hate on a system
you don't have if you don't have it you
can't talk about another thing if your
playstation do or xbox do and you don't
have an ex or pro who really don't want
to hear your opinions we mid generation
refreshing that's right this is do you
you better refresh refresh your fix face
cake so king riddle me this 2020 oh you
don't got that anaconda
if they go for that lock hard I'm not
anaconda don't come talk to you know the
many gopro-ed it calls it the Xbox the
Xbox one SD Xbox simple and don't have
the bushes edition when you try to fly
in and plug G and you know how I don't
want so the 20 by T's new resolution is
start more on them Lawrence and get your
game up I don't care what you gonna do
go get a job because you got extra time
on your hands make some money buy some
more experience things don't lock
yourself into these imaginary boxes
because this is the companies don't
really want y'all to be in these boxes
actually the company wants you to go out
and purchase competition and stuff like
that so you will buy multiple games off
notice I've done this stupid crap I've
brought the same game on both systems
just to see which one looks like it's
the pro version better
oh the X is running this way or that
proto god I'm here so listen so this way
y'all can actually have intelligent
conversations on Twitter opposed to this
this is this muddy stuff and stop acting
me in it just deaf singer we see you in
a jet I've been playing this tool rater
see this is how far back Oh shout-out to
Microsoft and Discover card
um the temp you guys are the greatest
thank you so much I appreciate all the
hard work that y'all do to get me these
free games I get every month let me tell
you out how to do it was very simple get
it Discover card
hey everything with it you got to get by
back dollars now if you purchase a gift
card with their affiliates then you get
an extra five dollars so I took $40 out
of my affiliate um
got a gift card for game stuff they gave
me 45 when you go to game stuff they
have Microsoft gift or package when like
a 15 15 and 15 that's um that's there
and then you have a $5 bonus they give
you a five dollar bonus gift card when
you buy the package and so in turn my
$40 turned into $50 and I used that to
purchase Tomb Raider and Isis create aa
de si Microsoft had the sale of 50% off
of the big package the hundred dollar
package and had it for 50 bucks both of
them that with the DLC and everything so
I purchase both of them and thank you
Microsoft and Discover Card listen those
easy game hacks off we ought to do if
you paying your bills get a card to get
you money back and we're affiliates that
you actually go to so you can finance
your video games your hobbies with out
using your dollars right looking getting
the credit lesson today we have the Lord
of the cooperative experience the gaming
ninja himself the shinobi law Cognito
surprise everyone is in the realm of the
ILP not telling you what you want to
hear but what you need to hear so for me
it's been like Vanessa made oh that's me
isn't achill for you to add to your own
and yes yes very very egotistical very
self crazy I like it finishing up my PC
master-race grind as you know I got that
no beast rig shout out to boxes for
hooking me up so long yeah but you're
not playing destiny on the PC are always
covered for you earlier all that bull on
the Xbox one and then you're doing it
all again on the PC created that that's
60 frames on cat row it is so
rat listen it's the destiny players it's
not about anything else it's just
destiny players I'm not insinuating
anything I'm directly saying this
Pleiades you still playing pocky yeah
and that's the reason I'm playing pub
jeez I didn't I didn't play pub G from
September until the end of November
because I had all those other greatness
to play he's playing with the Lee of the
elite he's not a little bougie
kognito has stepped up his game in
classes friends list is different all of
my all of my key bar is like Lord Mike
Ibarra definitely dragged him through
age so full disclosure man they are
beasts man he they run attack they are
that define the dishes sit the corner
and look pretty is come with me right
now
[Laughter]
I had destiny uninstall for a minute out
that will help scream shout out to
Ubuntu shout out to my tomorrow we've
been it's been a lot of fun man but I've
been doing that I've been doing the XCOM
tactical pack as well as have you know
things a diseased man so far laughs we
don't even play like that shortly it's
really cool it's the kind of like a
prequel and you get the the commander
guy that gives the commander the
missions inside the base it's like a
Cena yes it's amazing bro it's like
narrative Lee driven when you're on the
map and he's like telling the story pre
XCOM to how like the aliens took over
dude it's so good like if you it for the
hardcore ex-con fan and they even have
the old locales from like what is it
enemy Unknown all those old maps are
coming it's really cool so shout-out to
that I've been doing that a little bit
of messenger on the switch and I started
below on the Xbox one
I started dad yesterday so I'm just
getting my feel last time I came I
descend it down from the heaven is a
plan II will cuz you know you might go
anywhere
you know you look on the boxes I will
say this I'm counting out down the days
for game pass to come to PC I will say
that it wolf
what a technically it's already young
Pacey exactly yes technically it is you
are correct some pcs like it manually
just to play anywhere there's been a
fire like yes itself is a non piece
after your first was salute Lord Cedric
aah our first super chat of 2019 he said
shout out to all the lords on a panel
thank you sir thank you so much
appreciate it put a call on superjet so
yeah that's pretty much been it for me
ok challenge where you can kinda bro but
so are you a gamer urge we just call you
a destiny player I am a guy I am a gamer
as much as you're a pugsy player hey
back to I'll just say back to kognito I
beat spider-man
I'd be boom Raider beat red dead I beat
battlefield 5 I did all that and babji
did you stop playing pub G so here's the
thing my viewpoint to play all these
games that's what I said on the Xbox too
was as pub G is like that filler it's
that McDonald's burger that you have in
between those five-star meals the
lobsters those you get that spider-man
and it's a five-star steak right and you
say and you feed it right you play that
Tomb Raider and it's a lobster Oh
since we're doing all this analogy to
food destiny what kind of food is you
know what destiny is just like ramen
noodles he's got a point there if the
host starts turning into a PC master
dude like does that mean is it like a
disease is it gonna spread to us we are
in a Facebook put you on page right it's
new tech horse what happens is it's new
it's fun it's fresh is exciting he's
gonna do this right now the wheels one
dry the new systems come out that PC
right in the bushes you know it because
we're trying to come the only thing
holding back so what a condor comb I'm
good and this is really a first time for
kognito he's never a PC them having a PC
yeah what if see like a dude for the
last ten years so this is a whole new
world for me that I feel obviously
remained ignorant too ran wait video
card is not in circulation anymore $700
and download the new drivers that's when
he's gonna jump to save me you know
about this 4k TV I'm away for that self
an but anyway thanks man for coming at
me good you know you know me like I I
love Bungie they're my favorite they
were my favorite developer idols my
favorite franchise and Destiny's the
biggest disappointment of this entire
generation
the disrespect different from you why
you attack it ran over him covered it
gets you bad man is hurt a bungee did
him dirty because I was gonna win my
punchy head like when I was like you bro
I just downloaded it again um I think
was two weeks ago and monkey and um was
playing destiny I did all my destiny
stuff I did a Mayan man I was like come
on hey guys it's like a we going pub she
got over there by myself solo shout-out
to a one-way dragon oh yeah um the game
was like this poor and friendly and
stuff like that graphics and stuff at
least like named run smooth rain
fantastic right but soon as it launches
a little PlayStation this game is leaps
and mouths better than after it was
released got a lot of things name added
I've seen long as they keep supporting
minutes how do you think they took all
the resources to get the PlayStation
joint ready let the Xbox suffer for a
little bit so we can just implement that
stuff later and then now all of a sudden
the game i swears ninety you know i will
say one thing i played on I played pub G
and I played finally Clara at blackout I
got to say like pudgy still better than
blackout how about the table shut up
there's no want to try it do I haven't
tried it I heard blackout it's Call of
Duty oh my god that's me like I played
him it's Call of Duty I'd like I feel
like the difference is it the last 10 to
15 people is way more intense on pugsy
than ever I'm blackout really you know
one blackout what just like in the you
know the mime-version
mmm it could be worse pack me know you
could be a fortnight player Oh
that's true and I'm not about that life
but you at least ten people in this
chats a fortnight boy okay so that we
got into what the Lord's been playing I
want to start off with the Lords of the
Xbox too and being that both Lord Rama
and Lord Jays have already been giving
the Royal Treatment please check out ILP
number 28 in Aisle P number 60
respectively with each having some great
video game system history I want to do a
different approach which you do so Lord
Ram we'll start with you first let's do
the Xbox two origin story who they were
didn't prologue like you being a man
with the million gamerscore
and I'm standing YouTube success like
how did this dynamic duo come together
don't remember how when me and Jess
first started talking but there was a
point where we would actually get in a
Skype call and have these stories begin
with Skye I just wanted to know it's not
just you like I remember like all the
weapon will or just on Skye it'd be like
I'd have this information and I gotta
tell you this but I can't tell you to
text right I'm just like okay and then I
get in Skype and I tell him you have
something and we just have this like
gaming discussion and we're like you
know what I think it was jazz jazz said
we have sees like really cool
discussions but nobody's ever gonna hear
besides us maybe we should do a podcast
that sounds pretty good I was doing a
podcast with someone on Windows Center
at the time but it was really really
hard for us to line up our schedule so
we were like missing weeks and weeks at
a time
mm-hmm round is a bit more flexible and
accommodating so
[Laughter]
so obviously you've been friends prior
or was it like you've met at e3 like we
did what we did met we did meet at e3
okay so was that prior to the podcast
decision or after the podcast decision
we when do we start the pact we started
the podcast right before we met eight
Matty three before we we did the podcast
because yeah I forgot that we've had on
the show
mm-hmm yeah because I think we started
the podcast right before like a month
before Microsoft and digital founder
revealed the specs for Scorpio so was
like March of 2017
okay was when we did the show but I had
met Jazz at e3 2016 I remember going to
a event on a Monday night right after
the press conference and jazz was the
first one in line some marks off a move
to the front of the line yeah I guess we
just continued to talk and then you know
jazz would we'd talk and Skype when we
have some juicy nuggets of info to share
which a lot of it turned out to be true
some of them didn't you know but that's
how it is with some of these things and
there was like yeah these conversations
are great let's do a podcast and it was
like all right cool so it's like it was
Wednesday
it was Thursdays now it's just pretty
much whatever day cuz you know I guess
jezus schedules hectic sometimes you
know like I I'm busy or whatever so it's
like yeah it could be Wednesday might be
Thursday who knows it could even be
Friday
I got you got the name yeah you've guys
done a weekend I remember one time tunas
seen like a pop you guys pop up on a
Saturday or something weird like that
what something yeah that's cool so the
name now like who came up with the name
because I thought the name was cool
simple and go uh that was stick figure
stick figure yeah
first show we kind of just like like
anybody got any cool names
and heats up the Xbox too and I was like
hey that's that's pretty cool and you
know like if Microsoft does decide to
name the next Xbox Xbox to I expect
royalty checks I think is actually
pretty cool with what he could say that
because of obviously Beauty buzz as we
do the Destiny podcast we're in the
midst of a day change so it's kind of
cool cause we actually feel like version
of the it is not that name linked
directly to porno like when the
PlayStation got a whole of the porn
industry took that that's what the
PlayStation took off hey you never know
you might get that back
[Laughter]
windows central your informational
pieces blogging reporting a breaking
news alerts off clearly one of the very
best in gaming media so I'm not gonna
say any maintenance of course but in the
current climate of gaming it seems that
some in your position in field might be
threatened by the rise of the big
youtuber like ran threatened by me Josh
yes so what what allows you to coexist
with what's this generation subject in
this generation they label as
provocateur just like I do what I do
then as long as they pay me I'll keep
doing it
no then I'll move to something else it's
pretty much how to live life I used to
be an anime uh band I'd like I have
these fads where like I want to do
something I do it and I chase it as a
web developer for a while and AG report
of that you know make a blog blog for a
bit and talk this further than what are
the hobbies so okay so so what but I
still my question is like what me cuz I
get like this kind of like I don't wanna
say there's a civil war going on but
there's definitely people in your field
that I feel are threatened by guys like
Rand well there are two there are two
business models for blogs right one of
them one of them is effectively ad ad
driven now the a driven model is the one
you're talking about that struggle in
really and they're when they're driven
by ads they're driven by clicks they're
driven by trying to get you know people
to try to get people onto their website
right mm-hmm
Windows Central is not an ad driven
company we have a storefront we sell
mobile phone accessories and stuff like
that we sell software through we resell
software and stuff like that so I'm
really really lucky and blessed to be in
a position where I don't have to click
buy now you know you'll never see a
title on window central that doesn't
reflect the Conte
of the article you know we also focus a
lot on guides and stuff like that like
you know how to do your network and an
Xbox stuff like that and people come
through Google now we're lucky to be
more of a tech site than a game site
because it is like you say it is the
gaming the gaming blogs us the ones that
are sort of you know ones that people
said doing these shady tactics outraged
Bay and clickbait and stuff like that
but I mean really in that position as a
tech writer I'm lucky but I do I do
think about YouTube as well yeah a lot
of people just want to digest content
through YouTube and sometimes I think
maybe I should videos but at the same
time I'm also really lazy and a deaf man
I just love the canal I just love that
you two are able to co-exist because you
represent both sides and I think that's
dope you know saying because again it
does kind of make their uh that podcasts
unique there's no time you see someone
in the in the media like that what the
YouTube we're doing a place that that's
what I'm it's one of the best and I'm
also like Lord addict said it's like I
effectually we effectively like act as
if you guys are like the fortune tellers
of everything Xbox right so holding the
Lord to like some of the biggest leagues
the room is way ahead of time
yeah things I know everything about
everything yes right so how hard is it
to hold on to this information like in
this clickbait culture that's the first
part of question the second part is like
has Microsoft ever really been pissed at
you too but no it's Microsoft
mr. B hello that part was wolf it says
but I don't with the first part it just
like oh every video ran like there's a
good 40% chance someone's wrong with up
in my D I know that there are people I
expects you really don't like me that's
fine but like at the same time it's like
I'm competing with other leakers I
thought I actually I honestly don't like
leaking stuff I don't like
surprises if I if I can like if I can
keep hold of something and not spoil
like a big reveal at e3 I'll do it but
the thing is like I got competitors like
runs and stuff like that and I feel like
like there's a chance they're gonna leak
something like yeah like anaconda Brad
tweet and I'm gonna ride an Xbox
oh no he knows it's like just got that
just just makes those articles just in
case oh we do we have things pre-written
we have things pre written to publish in
case and out someone else he's gonna
leak it has there ever been something
that uh that you wanted to leak but then
it got leaked or you could yeah I think
so Ronda probably better than I remember
you know super chat right quick a turtle
should I question for jazz have you ever
considered ran to be part of window
central and move the podcast to be part
of window section well he trying to get
me a page I haven't told run this but
I've actually been trying to haven't
told round that because in case it
doesn't fold own to be disappoint but
[Laughter]
have you ever made a video that got
people pissed yes I made that crack down
video back in 2017 on that stream that
they did you guys know which one I'm
talking about it was it was warranted I
was proud of you but it was honest I had
a lot I had a few people at X Box hit me
up and yeah not appreciate that video
and then I had a bunch of people at X
Box say it needed to be said oh well
let's just say there was some people
powerful people that did not appreciate
that video yeah all and I learned really
quickly that it's sometimes it's about
how you say something rather like yes
and like you know what I mean like it's
nice how you say something like and I
thought maybe I was a little bit you
know I called it an abortion of a stream
they all did and someone else yeah
someone at Microsoft called me an
amateur and an idiot oh I really do I'm
saying well if I may be an amateur but
so is your crackdown marketing oh it's
all good though as for sitting up like
I've sat on so much info that I've never
said anything about like for instance
I'll give you two examples go for it
the Anaconda la carte I knew those two
code names and what they were a week
before Jazz posted and I could easily
have made a video saying that but I
really value the people that give me
tips I would never do that at all period
so I just sit on it and wait for
somebody else like jazz or Brad Sam's or
somebody down the line to then say
something and then I'd be like then I'll
make a video in another situation
because Jess will actually corroborates
this I knew digital foundry was going to
be checking out the ex that was a big
one that was didn't I didn't make a
video about it I waited until jessamine
what yeah I really did but but I knew
member cuz we were talking to PMS huh
I'm trying because you knew you knew a
part you knew a part of the story and
then I knew someone the other part of
the story and once I told you that you
you we put you know two and two together
oh and then yeah the song there's so
much that I just can never remember
anything yeah I remember back in the day
when the scalebound gang got cancer
rad was tied about there he was like I
was gonna make a video Tim talked me out
of making that scale bounce canceling I
went to boat and I said to jazz I'm like
I think scale bands cancelled and just
first words to me impossible they'll
never cancel scalebound oh man I I have
this guy who's hundred percent
everything he tells me turns out to be
true he says like there's major issues
with the game and all these different
things and I and him and Tim were like
dude you sound like Alex Jones right now
a week later just gets the exclusive
that it was cancelled when Ron told me
that I was like now there ain't no way
that cancel that the PR fallout that
question it has been terrible the people
still bring that up even now but like I
started I started digging and I was like
oh gosh runs it didn't run particularly
well and I thought crackdown ran better
than how that game ran yeah it wasn't
when I didn't look too good back but
just how did you feel when you find out
it was officially canceled it's like I
really want to talk to ran right yeah
why I was really shocked to be honest
because I didn't think they'd take the
PR hit but Phil Phil just maybe maybe
the old xbox wouldn't have taken the PR
hit but it was just like now I don't
know the real the full story behind all
of why it was cancelled and stuff like
that clearly they weren't happy with the
way things were going and rather than
just let them string string string it
along they just cancelled it and I think
I was
I was surprised and I think in that we
sort of got an insight into how
Microsoft are gonna do things when it
comes to yeah definitely their surprise
allotment at that Shakman net man when
that thing came out so salute the river
hold on it out it's not about views or
money like I value people's uh
confidence in me and Trust
nope so if people can tell me something
and I'm not going to make a youtube
video about it because nothing's worth
everything and I won't say anything
video about it you know it was funny is
then he sells out after this is complete
confident they told me all the secrets I
had to ask you to that question because
I know you guys go through it so I won't
even tell me things oh that's crap I
agree that rund actually secretly knows
everything that's happening is like
what's funny is almost every year and
makes an e3 I'm like oh you mean what's
gonna happen at e3 video I will say one
thing three last year you were so happy
he got one thing wrong like he was like
it's it's not gonna be there that would
it's gotta throw red herrings in there
you know he's gotta make it was there
yeah no I I think I said that oh yeah
you said Halo wasn't gonna be there well
that's how you know I don't know
everything or not I'm starting to think
started trip people good the real
prediction is you'll okay now we're
gonna put the [ __ ] in this data
your debut at the round table was all
the way back at i/o p28 so uh similar to
kids smooth you haven't been on since we
changed our format so what I'm gonna
need is Lord reigns top five video game
or franchises of all time of all time
assuming this tomorrow all time one halo
that's easy to like should not like
Final Fantasy - but like Final Fantasy
the frost oh okay
we're for just doing like strictly
franchise my favorite when I played the
most at 7-7 oh you would jazz that's why
you ingest one lot of people like six
more than someone that wrong I I'm gonna
get hate for saying this oh nine think
my favorites eight and now someone got a
boot boot is dude I suspect I enjoy 10
quite a bit but not as much as the other
three
I actually really like 13 okay let's see
so we got halo and Final Fantasy yeah
okay okay half-life
the game that blew my mind back when I
first played it on PC all those years
ago being like a guy a guy played doom
and I would play Wolfenstein right and
it's like kind of cartoony graphics or
whatever and you get to an end at the
end of the levels always you push a
button load them to the next right and
then you play half-life and you start a
game on it like a tram right and like
there's no end of the level it just
keeps on going and like to me that was
like mind-blowing at the time however
that just kind of was interlinked and
yeah so half-life is definitely top
three so we got halo we have Final
Fantasy Final Fantasy we have AF live so
we have two more this is the game that
defines you as a game but just for 9:02
special place in your life and none of
those barbie games for those achievers
barbie games and that was the case he
would say Lego I'm sure you've been her
I love that game we bought for like an
hour try to get the last of it I'm an AI
I don't know where this would be but I'm
just gonna say it
Resident Evil I don't know if that would
be five or four it is one of my fav
played pretty much all of them and I
love the franchise and just because I
don't want to take up that much more
time I'm gonna to say a franchise that
was my favorite from life scorn had two
of their games were my favorite from the
360 you know it probably I probably
would be Grand Theft Auto like I'd be
like Grand Theft Auto clear I love Grand
Theft Auto one that's kind of like the
easy thing I'll just say Bioshock okay
in BioShock Infinite we're like two of
my absolutely top five games from the
360 Jerry let me let me say it is that
I've held on the Lord Jesus top fire
from ILP 60 and this is why you two are
friends because he had number one final
fantasy seven he had a smoker's or
original BioShock and his number five
was Resident Evil 2 so you guys share
three top franchises now hits what
rounds out for Lord jazz he has a world
of warcraft and monster hunter world
so what Jags do your top five mean any
revising or you can franchises or games
franchises or games either one he's
about to take off I'm gonna I'm gonna
strip a monster like as a franchise I
really like month on to world but I have
applied the other games in the franchise
was the game applied so in that place I
probably put fallout 3 I've been gone
back in the start playing fallout I've
got about a hundred thirty I was in 76
the only person that I've spoke to that
even likes the game oh no I want to know
why now I'm not gonna sit and say that
it's some kind of amazing game because
it is a hot mess
I gave it six out of ten in our review
and you know and it's it's pretty it's
pretty lame how Bethesda treated
everyone when they launched this game it
was like did you get the canvas back I
didn't KIII ain't even talking about
that I'm talking about like basically
that that a beta test you had to pay to
get into which is yeah you could only
get into the bay if you pre-ordered the
game and like maybe if they've done a
real bad test maybe wouldn't be so
broken the game still broken like even
after like several major patches it's
still it's still rough you know and but
that said it does have really great
environmental stories
like holla types and stuff to explore
and but all the stories intersecting
interweave and people are discovering
all sorts of Secrets which I enjoy I
enjoy exploration games it's also got
that scavenging sort of survival
gameplay loop which I find addictive and
sort of almost meditative like like
Conan exhales I got like over 100 hours
in Conan X hours I like it's got that
and jazzed it does it have crafty we
know how you feel about that the whole
game the whole game revolves around
crafting because like the the plans for
crafting a rear air and when you get one
it's like oh yeah I got that cool plan
for a toilet I know I find it addictive
yeah it's like again I'm not putting
fallout 76 is the worst Fallout game I'm
not gonna sit here and climb otherwise
but as a franchise I've got like I've
got well over 200 hours on fallout 3 and
new Vegas and maybe about a hundred
thousand fallout 4 Wow
I love I love the franchise but
everybody was piling on the game and I
was interested in the game but very
afraid to even purchase the game from
all the negative stuff that I was
hearing from it and he's just the first
person that I heard that actually put in
the hours
well the game originally I wasn't even
gonna review the game one like I was
gonna get like one of our colleagues to
review it and I generally only I'm lucky
that you know cuz I'm in charge of the
game and coverage I only have to really
review game so I really care about where
it's like some of the other writers I
just say you've got to review this this
week and then you don't fire whoa
[Laughter]
YouTube is is a boss I make you know I
make every decision and if I don't want
to make a video I don't have to I'm an
awesome boss Mac Brown I'm sure anyway
but I after seeing all the hate the game
was getting and also because like I'm a
you know a fallout fan I thought you
know what I'm gonna I'm gonna give this
a proper you know going over and I've
actually written two reviews of the game
so of I read the scored review and then
last week I wrote the things that are
good about fallout 76 so if you are
interested in the game and you want to
know what part of the game are actually
fun and good things fall out on your
list we've taken monster hunter world
off we put in four if if we're talking
just franchises I'd have to probably put
Dragon Age and Mass Effect on there as
well I've got like I've got hundreds and
hundreds of hours in the Dragon Age
franchise to origins - so many times
well so like you must affect as well
Mass Effect 1 + 2 + 3 I actually like
three as well me too I'm even though
that's like the game everyone that
everyone gets all mad at the NBA and I'm
dromeda kind of like i SPECT 3 it was so
polarizing the polarizing yeah remember
they had to redo the ending they added
more content remember yes you know what
I mean I haven't actually gone back and
checked that out yeah you do you got to
do it because here's the thing depending
on with what
no spoilers what choices you picked
they've added more context to that
choice I mean the games like how old at
this point I know I just don't listen
right it's like when a game and starts
being like more than 200 years old
we came out in what 29 years old well
Pat the 99% the games are come on master
master factory or master Mass Effect
franchise in my top ten right right and
I've I'll say like the ending is the
worst thing I've ever seen to a
franchise but it didn't like the game
was Mandy whole game was the ending
right but let me let me loose finish the
saying it's like there's this talk about
like like it's break it down it's the
right way to say this right always go
always more about the journey rather
than the destination right okay okay so
even though the destination of Mass
Effect 3 was a trash heap right the
journey like that destination doesn't
negate the entire drag the suicide
mission for party games best games ever
met right so it's the fact that all like
they're hyping up Mass Effect and like
all these decisions how it matter and
the ending was literally it's either red
blue blue or green and I'm like that's
it red I have to ask you the question
after test your fraud miss now did you
go back after they updated the ended
after the outcry was just what you say
when the everyone agreed with you that
it wasn't up to snuff based on the
journey right did you go back yeah that
question too let's go
oh we as a person with the million
gamers core I watched it I watched the
stuff on YouTube I watch the changes
but I'm just saying like I still love
Mass Effect one two and three the
journey that I went on was amazing and
that can't be negated by that ridiculous
dumb ending I can't believe they thought
people would like that dude boom man
with the super charity $10 super chat
thank you so much bro much appreciated
what have you done that's that's my
flight buddy easy flight buddy I don't
get a flight but unless it's anchorman
you don't go anywhere you get a going
home flight buddy yeah to the airport
child to leonatus he said this is his
favorite podcast on the Citadel salute I
know but I I hate you man I ran I do
hear what you're saying and for three
games to culminate in that ending I
understand the outrage I completely
understand but in the same token I agree
with jazz that part two one leading up
and then part two itself man you know
I'm saying it was I didn't play the
third one but do my understanding like
the ending was the same regardless what
you choices were is that correct much
yeah
do feel like a little bit on rann side
you know if you completely revolve the
entire franchise around you know you
know the cause and effect system you
can't have the same ending whoa we got
sam alito Berdych I said when he
interviewed reek the drew cast version
he said is one of the it was of the
opinion that the team at Bauer simply
wasn't given enough time to properly
nail the ending for Mass Effect 3 so
what happened man about they let that a
dramaturg eat their after finishing that
ending right I was so disappointed I
know that I started to try to like like
this can't be like there's got to be
more to it and then that started
floating around about how Shepard was
indoctrinated
mmm-hmm I start to I'm like oh man if
that's the true ending Bravo to fire
because that's ballsy ballsy palsy and
then I remember angry Joe made a video
about it different and it was like man
this really lines up right feeling lines
up and then they're like no he's on a
dr. day like Melvin I agree I agree
those theories were actually better than
the last week's poll results are in in
the people spoke well last year in
regards to the recent ashen multi-player
set up FAQ released by the studio do you
think these steps are acceptable for
cooperative gaming I guess I gotta say
2019 now the winner at 51% of the vote
was that no this antiquated state of
coop is unacceptable no more friends
codes group coming in at second place at
33% was the I don't care
yah didn't keep that same energy with
monster hunter world co-op covered it at
last place with only 60 was interval was
the yes clearly a design choice by the
developer adds a unique charm to the
game group shout to all the lords who
participated in last year's poll
I gotta go straight the Lord rained Lord
rained you did a great review on this
how do you feel about these poll results
it what was the question again
Ash's cooperative yeah I don't
understand why they did that it doesn't
make any sense to me
like in 2019 if you make a game that's
co-op I should be able to easily invite
the person right now money involved I
think yeah I mean I was able to play the
entire game of co-op with my friend so
it didn't impact me right but I know it
impacted other people and I can I get
what the debate almost gave kids to be
the heart attack yeah I get what they
wanted to do wanted they wanted to have
that kind of journey vibe to it like at
any point in time
it's a real person a not an AI character
but it did seem like it was poorly
implemented the fact that I had there
like we both had to check on the
multiplayer filter and put in the same
code like handle switch and action is a
cool game to like I especially co-op so
I did it that way that's weird
I agree hopefully with fingers crossed
we won't spoil too much but hopefully we
the Lords should be getting some answers
soon from one of the developers so stay
tuned for that so we were tight with
those guys and a pure when I interviewed
them I told them not even to put the
friend code in mmm oh so you when they
saved it by even throwing the friend
code it now oh no no I told them not to
add that I was just like to leave it
completely oh just once they see the
world burn you could play strangers oh
you got to put another feature where you
can play with your friends though we
don't need that we want to play with
nothing but strangers this is what
everyone Oh stay tuned for the latest
poll that I'll be cooking up at the end
of the show let's get into these topics
laws we got a lot to discuss so um we're
gonna start off with Microsoft and um
it's multifaceted next-gen approach so
uh here the room is that we know thus
far I wanna shout out Lord jazz Lord
rain of course and Lord Brad Sam's he's
been on it as well and a lot of random
J's you guys can feel free to update me
if my information is incorrect because I
know we were away I hope it was away
when a lot of this stuff yes so first
what we have is the current generation
of Xbox one as kind of like being some
revision with the Maverick right almost
like a diskless Xbox 1s possibly 2019
and then we're hearing about the Roma
right which appears to be some kind of
digital onboarding service should I say
Jays is that that correct Ram is it like
some kind of onboarding Roma so to speak
in conjunction with yes oh you guys
don't know okay so we're gonna leave a
link down
Roma was more sort of like Pia kind of
the evolution of you WP
and yes it's all one thing okay fair
enough
yeah go on okay so we got that and then
we have um we also heard about anthem
which is not the EA game but the project
X cloud kind of sent it around the Xbox
one as architecture then moving on we
kind of got the big boys which is the
scarlet family the next generation
devices which should consist of Lockhart
you know which again the scarlet
next-gen equivalent of the Xbox one s
and of course the big boy the anaconda
which would be the high end or the you
know the scarlet pro so rounding all out
of all of this will be you know an
accounting equivalent of the projects
cloud we're still hearing about more
studio acquisitions great video ran by
the way um possible VR the expansion of
game paths and shout to largesse going
on this one with the patents for some
Xbox resistive controller designs so all
this is still rumor all in speculations
with very good sources some in the room
but um just based on what we currently
know that for in your opinion is this
multi prong approach is it the correct
direction are Microsoft or is do you
think this is just way too confusing for
the average consumer I know I've had
some extra thoughts about this recently
because obviously me and Brad have
completely different sourcing on this
because yeah he had more information
about he had Romo I never heard a rumor
or anything like that
I think Romo is the digital onboarding
service not right the uwp thing which is
crying so he had he had definitely
definitely a different sourcing of me
now I don't know for a fact for a fact
that it's gonna release as two devices
what it might be is that these are two
separate prototype devices and there
might end they might end up deciding to
go with just one of them and there's any
hard evidence right now they're gonna
release to skews now there may well be
releasing to excuse but at the very
least there are two scarlet consoles
that exist today have the
in specs and that's what that's what
they're working with right now
I don't know if you guys have been seen
in the news recently but Apple has
recently taken pretty massive stock here
and a lot of controversy about about its
approach to the latest iPhone line hmm
and how they were saying like the iPhone
exciting cell as well as they thought
and and stuff like that because like
even though their iPhone exercise really
good device it's still seen by people as
the the bad iPhone mmm they can't afford
the good iPhone so they just completely
skipped over it completely right I think
there's like I think there's definitely
an argument to be made that releasing
two different SKUs could be confusing
for consumers or even just like it could
like completely undermine the idea of
having like someone be like oh I'll just
get the excess but then um I just get
the the s2 or the Scarlet the Scarlet
light should we call it I'll just get
that and and that'll be the console that
everyone regards as the bad console
gadget would you mean you referring the
Lockhart is what you saying yeah the
console that people regard as a bad
console and I might just end up going to
PlayStation just so they don't have to
make that choice I was just gonna say I
do think that with the mid generation is
this gen I think next gen if you launch
with - it'll be a little bit more open
to it because you know we've we've dealt
with mijin's for a couple years now so
people they're at least a little bit
more you know a noticeable when it comes
to two different kinds of skews I think
I think the way if they're gonna if I
are gonna go to to skews I think the the
lower end skewed needs to be
significantly cheaper so that can so
that can be like so so it can sort of
slip into that sort of budget-conscious
market if it's just slightly cheaper
then they're kind of they're kind of
undermining them right so we're talking
300 for Lockhart 400 for PlayStation 5
five
for anaconda right that's significantly
cheaper yeah
yeah I would say so okay because I
wonder how people like I wonder how
people would react that would be
interested if Lockhart is has like less
teraflops than say the X right
apparently now apparently this the
current rumor is that Lockhart is either
lower spec or equivalent to the X and
that it will be boosted by the C feels
right because that's what I was thinking
like you yeah and like hardware
refinements because you go remember the
current Xbox operating system is a bit
of a mess that's why you know the
dashboard is like as it is and so there
might be like there's there's a range of
things that can do to get more juice out
of it but keep the cost down and cooling
is one of them shoutout to Ryan a
professional thank you sir
much appreciate it continue rain-x has
the liquid cooling system right so if
they can come up with a solution that is
a little bit more cost-effective and
with the new CPU inside I see I say
probably keep the same specs but if they
can change the the cooling I think it
can bring the cost down I'm saying like
270 1999 for the cheaper version to make
it come in with that price because like
when you flash a price point on the
screen or were you walk into the store
and you see a price point of like $2.99
we all know it's $300 but it's something
the way that is shown it tricks your
brain into affordable right and instead
of saying 300 but 299 weird dollar
changes your opinion of it they want
that first number being in the smaller
number than it right here right so okay
so it comes in
let's say comes in $100 cheaper than the
PlayStation 5 right which will be at a
higher spec than at lower spec Xbox but
then you have the highest spec Xbox
which will probably be 500 um I don't
think it's gonna be too much confusion
because I believe the masses the early
on masses gravitate towards the cheaper
option you can get the same amount of
gameplay out um for cheaper right they
will go with the cheap option let me let
me ask you King and let me ask Tran this
now as far as the get that multi SKU
approach we're assuming with Scarlett
with Lockhart and anaconda like do you
think this may be a result of them
looking at the success of the Xbox one X
right and remember it let's be honest
like when the X was announced its kind
of announced at the same time the S was
debuting so to speak and everybody was
like no what are you doing
remember like it's like a mistake you
can't do that so like do you think
because of the success of the X that
they're extra confident now to say hey
this is something that we can provide
almost like a cellphone model source V
Graham I don't think it's confusing that
there's to like like I mean that they
did it with the 360 there was the pro in
the arcade one had the hard drive I
don't think I don't think a few
consumers will be confused that hey
here's one this plays games better than
the other what could be confusing is is
the axe in the Estel being carried
forward and what games work where yeah
like let's say hypothetically the rumors
are true and it's two systems in the
future right you have anaconda you have
Lockhart but they're still gonna be
selling the X and they're still gonna be
selling the X and yes and then
supposedly there's also the diskless one
maverick right five SKUs store shelves
at 2020 now that could be a little I
could see being confusing someone who's
not in the know not the hard core like
we'll know right right people listed in
this podcast will know
the hardcore gamers who are buying a day
one will know but I can see that being a
little bit confusing to something
because they'd be like so does the ex
play the new you know what I mean like
that could be a look confusing because
I'm still not really sure on what the
future I think yeah I'm just not really
sure what the future of the ex and the s
are going to be your Microsoft
especially with you know that another
diskless version so right until that
kind of until we start seeing
Microsoft's messaging on this you know I
don't know like I I kind of I kind of do
think they are gonna release two systems
because from the rumors it's like one
systems like incredibly more powerful
than the other right and I understand
like you know cuz because I believe Sony
did this with neo when it was called
name you know neo with the pro they had
one version that was more powerful but
more expensive and then one version that
was cheaper and it was like okay one
some point they decided we're just gonna
do this one I mean jess is right in that
aspect where it literally could be these
are the two systems were thinking about
releasing and we're gonna kick one right
but they do seem to be kind of like
really far apart spec wise where it's
like are they is it are they really like
we're either gonna go balls to the wall
we're gonna release a system that's
gonna get destroyed by the PlayStation 5
and spec right right it's like okay I'm
not really sure those are like kind of
two comparable choices there so to me
and almost reads like they're it's gonna
be two SKUs there's gonna be two SKUs
because I don't believe Phil gives up
the power narrative like he said my
believing his own record that won't ever
happen again so in that respect I do
believe that they're gonna go with the
two options but I think they kill off
the S and I believe because uh shout out
to digital foundry and they just did a
video with it was the end of an arrow
with the S and I believe you know they
kill that off and I do believe in that
same genre in the same
area the X fall catches the ax as well
because that's what Lord J's said last
time we had him it's move asked him of
the fate of the exit just said
irrelevant those two skills become the
dominant in the hierarchy I believe they
those two so what about this maverick
that isn't us that's what I was just
getting ax before it you can even live I
believe it dies I believe it was is a
concept that they put out it was the
idea behind maverick is literally the
clues in the code name it's it's
designed to do something different and
they're basically sending out to see how
the market responds to it they spent
testing the wars to see if people really
are truly that married to the disk drive
or not they've got two years basically
to see how well maverick performs
against the regular disk based s I can
see well you know is it worth us having
multiple skews of scarlet consoles that
have disk drives and don't have
destroyed you know right like they are
testing the waters there and they need
to because if if a competitor like I
don't know let's just say Apple or
Google for example if a competitor comes
along and they come with a disc list SKU
and people love it and Microsoft and
Sony don't have that option
and they get their pants down in over
there we're under the company's
innovated and predicted the market
better than they are so they're not
leaving anything to chance and I think
Mark the whole point of maverick is to
test the war Google what is it Amazon
have released dismiss skews yeah exactly
exactly it's just like an example if
unlike Google has like extreme there's
some like extreme challenges that Google
would have to get to a point where they
could challenge Xbox and PlayStation I'm
just saying like no it's it's
Microsoft has this sort of I don't know
almost like trepidation now when it
comes to hardware because
that they totally screwed up smartphones
but Microsoft could have been you know
the smartphone King that everything
positioned properly to become the
smartphone kings and they screwed it up
and you know they Amazon just announced
that they've sold 100 million echo
devices now Microsoft could have been
there too but they they screwed it up
and um so I think like where like in the
past or other Microsoft divisions have
sort of not innovated fast enough I
think Xbox is sort of like you know what
we can't afford to not try these things
you know right absolutely absolutely we
have some comments in before I get it to
solve you know at it Oh matt says they'd
be better off keeping the Xbox 1x alive
selling it for 300 and O'Connor for 500
Sam Tolbert he had mentioned that uh he
thinks they need to stay away from the
one branding to make the distinction
clear for their scarlet brand so I
actually agree with him on that
big-time they will because anything the
word one in it from here on out yeah the
whole point of the one in Xbox one
refers to one core which is which was
the sort of Windows 10 core sort of it
wasn't it wasn't the rumor that's why
they skip Windows 9 to go to Tim was for
the one thing I don't know why they did
that but the thing is there the Xbox the
next Xbox is moving again to a new sort
of Windows core which they're literally
which is literally called Windows core
OS right now mmm it could be called you
know thinking about Mads comment yes
$300 I literally had this conversation
with dealer last night because we were
talking about the Lord dealer if you go
on Best Buy in the web sites and Game
Stop the X is currently selling for $500
now if we assume these new consoles are
coming out in two years is it feasible
Microsoft can cut the price on the X by
$200
in the next two years and is there any
indication of anything they've done with
their pricing on any of the Xbox models
going but dating back to the 360 that
would say yes they are going to drop a
hundred dollars each year to get to the
point where when the next-gen comes good
point X is 300 which would be right at
the price of Lockhart which is not a
very good value proposition why are you
selling the X at 301 this Lockhart
supposedly is 300 right we're assuming
but as yet they were better it's I don't
know what they're gonna do because I
just can't see like I see maybe a
hundred dollars if I can see the the the
X being $400 a $50 price cut permanent
this year a $50 price cut permanent in
2020 I think getting it down to 300 by
the end of 2020 is a tall order really
like I said I don't know what
Microsoft's messaging and what they're
doing so I don't I don't know their
plans for the X and the s right clearly
they have some sort of plans for the S
because they built their entire server
rack for X cloud which is the next point
I'll get into before you go but more
time I'm not a tech dude I don't really
know much of this stuff but to me that
says like it's it's like they're gonna
like the X will be viable in some way in
the future streaming you know games to
your phones or whatever and maybe just
has more information about this or you
know more about I'm sure dealer would
because when it comes to this stuff but
it's important to note like the the
number one thing that's gonna differ
between the one consoles and the scarlet
consoles is the development platform so
I like during the lifecycle of scarlet
Microsoft they're gonna try and push
debs over to a different development
platform well you know this is this is
my prediction speculation definitely
poured around
[Laughter]
because plans plans can and do change
once upon a time there those they were
gonna release the surface mini and like
that cancel they're literally a week
before launch so like when you have to
be careful making predictions with these
tech companies you know they they don't
care they'll cancel something at a
moment's notice
they're not it's not like Apple
especially with Microsoft they're
they're harder to predict because there
isn't like a single business Microsoft
that really matters that much it's like
where if Apple cancel a live phone but
the last minute it would kill their
business well marks but if Microsoft
Microsoft candle eye things and that
their whole business would still be
saved so one of the people over there in
the elite control he said like they
almost canceled it a week before that
came out basically the the thing to know
about the the the main difference
between the scarlet family in the one
family is this concept of game core OS
which is a new a new development
platform for Xbox and PC so it's sort of
like extending what they've done with
you to appear where developer can make a
game once and extend it across both
consoles not many games actually use it
right now I think like fallout shelter
is one of them know you can you can
guess how powerful it is the answer is
not very perfect I've been told that
game core OS is more win32 like for
those who know when 32 is like yeah
basically the kind of game you get on
Steam in that in that sense the the 1x
won't be able to play again that's made
with core OS that runs across PC and
Xbox so at some point during the
lifecycle of a main round of discussed
whether this yeah we we were on two
different sides there I said at some
point there would be a clear cut off and
in the sand
games are only be playable on scarlet
and not on the regular ones and you
always you always took the opposite
approach you said that they would be
playable across all devices which I was
wrong you're right I
I like that the Hornets intentionally
just fell okay you're not gloating over
because like you like older technology
behind you know I I assume that is why
assumed was that Mike's offered develop
YouTube EP out to a point where they can
put you to repeal on the One X and you
know and it would work across both but
now obviously now new information comes
to light they just want to abandon like
just gonna abandon you to be paying and
well not abandoning but you did have a
good thing where you said Microsoft
might be going to developers and be
listen like you were gonna have this new
gen but you still have these forty some
odd million older you know Xbox 1s Xbox
one ex owners that you can sell games to
unlike the PlayStation 5 which is a
refresh you're selling at zero right and
you were and then that kind of fits with
micro offices this whole strategy of
what they're actually doing as a company
and you we both when we talked about
that you were like I think that's what
they're gonna do and I'm like I'm not
really sure I think at some point is
this gonna be like this is for Scarlett
and that's it anything they've been
saying to this point yes yeah I don't
think I I'd understand a game core it
functions differently the new WP right
and that is that is that the sort of
evolution of it but I think the fact
that they talked about game core being
up within it you're able to create sort
of more like container based things much
like what they did with back compact
we're back compat is literally a
container that emulates hardware in it
well I know I know just so you don't you
know silos of stuff and that may
contradict you III know
shut you down
I just know I just know what I know I
know four five so this is your
predictions got you I know for a fact
that the scholar the Scarlet consoles
will be fully backward-compatible I know
that scarlet consoles bait they've run
the same development platform
environment as the Xbox one platform and
they have to because that's how you get
backwards compatibility and like you say
it runs in a container a xbox one
retainer right but from what I
understand game core is less container
ish put it in a technical it's like it
is more exposed like you like win32 like
they talk about mod like from what I've
seen is they talked about modding
injection based mods which are like the
sort of the mods that people even refer
to as mods injection base mods they're
more like developers will probably call
them hacks but the ones that people want
you know not more like Bethesda style
mods where they so they are part of the
container or wherever but general let's
get those like job please absolutely
please and then let's get ups good
technical order here saw man like what
are you feeling general with all that
all these cold words all these things
you asked anthem anacondas Mavericks
lack hearts like the question that I
have is is nobody's necessarily
mentioned anthem so with everybody's
talking about - skews yes
how does anthem figure into this it's X
cloud I do not think they're gonna give
us something that is X cloud specific at
a separable price point yes
you know what's you know it's funny
because I thought that what I thought
maverick was sort of the vessel for that
so at least the beginnings of that you
know what's funny is his judgments and
things that he hears or whatever that
you know old plans change
Jezz are we even sure there's a
streaming console anymore
honestly that's a that's a broad
something I don't I don't know I heard
that there is no streaming console yeah
my I've never that's I've never heard
anything about streaming console mmm
interesting because that was the initial
rumor right that was yeah dedicated
streaming box and now it's kind of again
the latest things that we've been
hearing is kind of like what like anthem
is almost like a project x cloud
centered around s and then we should
have another version of project x cloud
which is centered around anaconda and if
honda so it's confusing it's confusing
and but based on what we've been hearing
I can't agree with you ran like I'm not
hearing about the dedicated streaming
box yeah because I remember Brad Sam's
dropped that info he said there be
streaming console right and did and
everybody freaked out
because they're like Microsoft's go
would stream it doesn't even know like
Brett seems to say they're doing a
traditional console he did had more info
about the streaming thing which you know
just says he's never heard about I heard
recently that you know there may be no
streaming console maybe Brad had his you
know miscommunication which happens all
the time maybe no it was the diskless
Xbox or whatever that yeah I just don't
know and Mike I don't know like I am
curious to see how X cloud is going to
be positioned right like what is if
there's a paper right I think like
streaming service is it going to be free
or is it was it going to be locked
behind some sort of subscription well
Microsoft's say you know what if you
subscribe to game pass stream as much as
you want you know like and I'm it's
gonna be really cuz we don't know
anything about the X code other than
that like little video they made four
minute video we don't know how many
games are gonna be streamable this is
the thing this is the thing about X
cloud if those those server racks are
based on the Xbox one s or Xbox one X
means that if you want your game to be
on X cloud you need to have the
core stuff in it as well that sort of
confuses the whole argument hmm it is if
you want get out you want my opinion I
think that X class is gonna be revolved
around game pass like it's gonna be
there you know they're gonna always make
sure that those games are really
friendly with X cloud and they're gonna
try to sell that on you know game pads
you can play all these games on your
mobile device
yeah one one big based on the fact how
they're beefing up you know game Pass
recently into such a quality service and
it's something that they're really
pushing hard so one would think that
obviously you know that they want to
push X cloud they want to push that
service on it but I'm with Rand in the
sense that how do they solve the point
of entry right how do you get this in
because you can't say I mean King has
had this discussion many times where you
can't say okay you're gonna pay for Xbox
Live Gold and then you're gonna have to
get the game pass like you can't tell
that to the mobile market I think this
is just an opinion because I have no
effect and I don't work for Microsoft
but my opinion of it is they kill off
life live has been the biggest barrier
when it came to the PC right beautiful
PC those guys don't have to pay for it
though and you know the console guys has
always been an uproar oh we have to pay
for it you know and oh yeah for a period
of time before you would say and put up
the quality of it right but you had to
have something in place that can give
you the value and replace it game pass
gives you that value because they're
giving away now if you happen to get
game past and you have live you're
getting free every month it's not free
you pay for it
but um you're getting an honor average
of probably 10 games a month mm-hmm
right they have to find a way to cut
that bleeding put them all into game
paths to show the value of game past and
to take away the barrier of the live
right so now we're all about that
revenue stream King us out
or you can walk away from bro you don't
lose it when you bundle all of that
information all that stuff into being
pass you can say right I don't think
that went raising the price of game pass
game s my dollars let's say they raise
the prices right now is a crazy value
it's $1 o that covers life for the whole
year right right right and you get the
game pass lifts the live with the French
and all that other stuff but that's
something that you can bundle to put to
your phones to put to your tablets and
it comes with games already so you're
just not paying just a multi play with
your friends you're paying for a service
that all that stuff is extra but you
really per games you understand so you
have the 200 games off the rip and every
month they will instead of just
releasing them separately for live and
and separately for game pass they would
just release those same games that they
was gonna resell live inside game pass
mmm that's right I mean it is
interesting I won't jump in there this
is all this stuff is interesting to me I
think the key I want to shout out I
wanna shout you guys at plan an Xbox
house listen you guys are sweet it's a
messaging man I mean all I think about
is messaging messaging messaging and we
go back to 2013 reneges and I just
cringe at that one of the worst reveals
ever you know said and you know with
digital sharing always online they use
games and how they got killed and of
course shout-out to the dawn who had us
by another talk about he had another
system for you but you know that's the
over gene you know that's over gene we
know fillers in there he's changed the
culture you know and I think right now
with services and he's got two victories
the first to me is the success of the
mid console refresh he's proved with the
X you know a lot of people out of us as
games even question it
you know with them revealing it when
they revealed it but you know we have
piscatella on the show the NPD numbers
have shown you know saying actually be a
tremendous success and console revenue
you know me so I think that's kind of
giving them that confidence to say hey
we can do a two prong approach you know
I'm saying but again it's got to be the
messaging and then this
has just been the victory of of game
pass and just making I think they're in
the point of making the point of entry
so easy that you don't have an excuse
not to have an Xbox right they're doing
things with game pastic like the
one-dollar thing and you know I'm saying
like they wants you in that ecosystem at
all cost and I think if they can again
this is a big if now if the ultimate
wild car is gonna be X cloud if they can
prove that they have an efficient low
latency vehicle for gaming
right and it's leaps and bounds beyond
like a PS now and so on and so forth and
they've got that Azure infrastructure
behind them they could be in position to
dominate with that wild card in my
opinion but again big if big marketing
the PR better be on point the SKU
information the breakdown better be on
point those who have the s and the X
what happens to them that information
gotta be on point you know I'm saying if
they're able to do that they can be in
preparation for the PS 5 that's just my
opinion
I believe it with a J's and ran for you
to close out to stop it jazz you want to
uh want touch on this I mean you said
it's just like it's all about messaging
if they are gonna do are gonna do too
and it's got to be positioned in a way
that one doesn't undermine the other
like we've seen with the iPhone X or
whatever they are we've got a they've
got a you know make sure that X cloud is
demonstrably are you for money you know
they well they are probably gonna charge
for it cuz it's gonna cost a lot to run
that stuff bandwidth ain't free it's
cheaper for Microsoft cuz they have
their own data centers obviously but
still do you think it's abundant with
the subscription then like game pass or
its own thing like will they actually
have a third subscription where it's
like sign up for X cloud subscription
yeah I mean that's that's the wild card
you know it's kind of like I'm of the
I mean if I had to guess and again I
don't know what they're doing but if I
had to guess I would say it's a tier of
Xbox game pass probably no interest game
pass is so important to Microsoft it is
that if they can get its it's such a
cheap it's such a cheap price per month
plus you get all the games that and if
you're going after the mobile market
like like King said they're not gonna be
paint like the mobile market wants stuff
for free you're not thinking about hey
you want to play Halo Infinite sure on
my phone yeah how much is it well it's
$10 and the nerds are gonna pay another
60 to play it online that's that's DOA
right I do you also gotta think like
okay Microsoft's gonna have a competitor
in the space and that's Google right no
they're coming
Google gonna charge for their service
can Google can Google come in there and
be like you know what you want to play
Assassin's Creed Odyssey stream it right
you buy the game or whatever it is we
won't charge you to stream the game but
every half an hour you gotta watch an ad
because they do run YouTube and if
whatever Google is doing if they run it
free and Microsoft has to be like well
we can't charge for it right like they
would have to be like it's free over
here - it's gonna be very interesting to
see how this whole thing comes together
absolutely I think it's awesome I think
I think the tech is in people's minds a
sketch is still sketchy enough that they
can't get away with charging for it in
any capacity you have to hide that ball
somewhere and for it I have Google
charges for it again they have to be
demonstrably better to be able to charge
for it I just don't think I could again
you would talk about the mind of the
console gamer as opposed to the mind of
the the casual gamer sort of or somebody
who might be kind of a meaning towards
seeing what you know Google an online
platform from Google looks like a guy
I've been playing it and it's again when
it's great it's great it's like I'm
playing it on an S when it's not not so
much like you know you
have a lot of artifacts and stuff like
that so it's there so my that's that's
my starting off point and for me for me
to really be excited about X cloud it
has to show that it's better than that
now let me add a stand on a mobile
platform as well because the address off
because you you've tested it you've
tested the what is it the Google service
what the assess right and you you you
came away very impressed right from your
early testing yeah very impressed with
what what how the game plays and I'm not
gonna lie this is the best it is the
absolute best now the only thing is X
cloud is touting this sort of this sort
of lack of a lag on mobile devices right
about 5g and stuff like that and I think
when they talk about the games running
that well on a mobile device this D on
Wi-Fi they really talk about 5g right um
because when I tried to play it on Wi-Fi
in my house like again not more than a
few feet away from my router it wasn't
pretty
I think I got a surprise you you do
magic to make that work right guys I'm
with you because I've heard some things
as well um you know to the point of I
don't want to say arrogance but extreme
confidence from what I for in reference
to X cloud the things I'm hearing is
prepared to be blown away that this this
is not going to be a PS now kind of a
situation right because theoretically
traditionally what we've always felt
about streaming has always been that
yeah you can play some turn-based kind
of stuff you're not I'm saying yeah you
can play some maybe side-scrolling kind
of stuff but when it came comes to fast
twitch you really can't do that right
you come to FPS and in fighting games
and you don't think that kind of thing
you know notoriously you're like you
won't be able to do that so you know if
they're able to pull this thing off man
in that would be a huge feather in
Microsoft's cap you know what's right
you know what's the most important thing
now go for it they may haven't even
talked about let's go the games bro oh
absolutely you know I mean Microsoft for
me want us they want on the shopping
spree this year got some Studios
call-girl thrown out tweets today about
some studio with some human stuff right
we hear in Norse through your video more
studio album yeah I mean you know I
think it's gonna happen and and and good
because they said it was I I'm gonna be
brutally honest go for it
Microsoft's first party this gen last
gen a variety in Microsoft those are two
words that should never be used to
affect conversations to people may think
Microsoft has this big variety on Xbox
and I'm like do you know who their first
party studios are and it's like turn 10
it's three for three it's the coalition
it's rare and it's Mojang it's like so
what have they done this chen Oh Forza
Motorsport 5 6 & 7
I'll give them 4 horizon for because
they acquired playground games by that
point gears ultimate gears for halo
Master Chief collection
halo 5 and CEO thieves yeah this is a
scream variety to me screams that's not
very good in fact you didn't get rid of
gears ultimate mastery of collection
because they were outsourced yeah so not
many games they made right the most
important thing for next-gen to me like
yeah I'm excited for anaconda and I'll
check out the ex-cop stuff which I am
kind of like I want to see y'all want to
see the tech in my hands right hmm
but it's about obsidian it's about Ninja
Theory it's about playground games
second studio you know it's about undead
labs actually making you know a proper
sequel to state of decay instead of
state of decay 1.5 right with the
recession
I want to see that because I want to see
the diversity the technology the what
the initiative the quadruple a studio
that they're building these are the
games that are going to sell these
next-gen consoles and the X cloud
service and game pass and that's the
most thing I'm most excited about to be
honest and I got a video coming out soon
about this I've never been more excited
about the future Xbox than I am today no
I always how it surprised by that video
cuz you get up that you're a pessimist
ran but you're you're realist like
nowadays and you know a lot of times
lately this generation in Xbox fans have
not been happy with you when you've been
brutally honest or certain things I mean
you come out with a almost of positivity
video on the future and it's bright I
think they're gonna have a great year in
2019 I think or in Gears or five are
gonna be amazing right
but I'm talking next-gen like instead of
just Halo fours and gears which we're
gonna get we're gonna get so many
different types of games and different
genres that you weren't gonna be able to
get and it's just like I look at him
like finally this is what I wanted them
to do last generation yes this is what I
wanted them to do to get like to build
their studios like Sony's at now Sony's
at their position out well they have all
these great studios and they're working
together and they're on their second
third and fourth game and they're
starting to really hit their stride with
something is like Microsoft didn't have
15 years to invested if people okay
we're gonna have to just use money
internal conflict and what was going on
like you really can't have the house
fight and expect it to go right at some
point I believe Sony was in line with I
mean they took the early struggles
people fail to realize and they forget I
was there from the beginning I was there
from the death of Sega on to the birth
of Sony on and forward right people fail
to realize when Sony came in you know
other people that would have the
revisionist history and stuff like that
that's cool
but I seen the growing pains right and
it has
bear fruit now that these games are
back-to-back Game of the Year winners
these studios are propped up as the best
studios that you can get in gaming and
they're not stopping out I honestly
believe next year Sony will acquire
studios as well I believe
oh I didn't get it because they
understand that the onslaught is coming
from the Google's and and Hank may be
from Apple himself acquiring them in
some form of fashion but Microsoft I
think the internal struggle is over and
and it's actually in a given feel that
okay because honestly I thought that was
the low point because we hit our stride
with Peter and I thought we were got a
man we were right there and I say we
because I fight for the underdog I
always fight for the underdog all right
and Microsoft coming in that space I
told you before that's not but if people
we want it we want it Sega and any form
of capacity we wanted Sega Microsoft's
took him stepped into a place and took
that spot they are our de facto Sega I
would give me that so far for them to
get to this point they seem something
something clicked yeah they took a loss
this year because Sony clean sweet
beautiful games great I'm talking about
from story to graphics to beginning to
end nobody complained about the ending
of any of these games right they from
beginning to end these games was
fantastic and they had the multiplex
they stole away the rights of certain
multiplayer games of distribution and
promoting they're doing it right and
Microsoft sees this and I believe
they're in harmony now and as the change
is gonna come like Rand said that burger
fries and Shake I think that stuff is
over mm-hmm yohoo saying come before you
said King how you fighting for the
underdog native riches company to work
your mother could be rich
but are you rich mmm I'm gonna give it
to you that way so you can understand
exactly what I'm talking about
they were never viewed as Microsoft the
company mm-hmm you know understand there
are like an xbox like a being like
almost a sitter right now okay right the
Xbox doesn't control the purse strings
of Microsoft cuz there are certain times
like take twos extremely rich but you
know we don't go to the people who make
like XCOM and stuff we like why don't
you got more I think so don't look at it
as Microsoft the company is extremely
rich take the whole mentality let's say
your parents are rich you got money you
just don't have their money fact are we
going and let's be honest Terry Myerson
situation and now fill in at the table
it's a different structure now right we
don't agree that it's not the same very
good now right the studios being
purchased
you see people talking about we're going
over to Japan to purchase real estate
over there is it difference when you're
sitting at the big-boy table for
Thanksgiving or pose a sitting at the
little kid's table on the side enough
this is tough I know adding you've got a
role soon attic so do you want to jump
off the the next one real quick man with
uh yeah I'll go ahead and um you know do
the topic and do my perspective but then
I gotta bounce
I don't get a mouth so cut off man
what's going on so Activision apparently
you know I didn't realize I don't think
ok here's the thing you know my topic is
gonna be what's Activision looking like
in 2019 if you look at last year like
the only real success that they claim
I'm gonna put that successful have my
camera out using quotation sponsor a
camera on anymore
but um so apparently like the only real
success that they had last year and once
again success in quotations Call of Duty
you know being the number one selling
game but they
said underperformed their expectations
so my first off let's start there how
are you going to outsell everything in
the whole year and it underperformed you
I don't get that okay we'll keep going
from there so we get the Destiny -
apparently forsaken was huge under there
under there
you know what the aim to make not said
underperformed disappointed in destiny -
first and regardless what Ram feels
about it the game with the game deck
here's the thing like me I do give that
a little bit of pass because it probably
did on to perform what you know they
expected to make but you can't come out
well you know good six months before
that and you know be throwing softball
and then you finally have that you know
that that homerun and it's like you've
been showing me this so a lot of people
were skeptical would even buy it because
of that so you know then you go to
overwatch has been on the decline know
that's you know but Blizzard and
Activision are actually you know the
same company pretty much but you know
overwatch has been on the huge decline
it and realized this but you know ever
since the Battle Royale genre took over
it completely cannibalized over watches
fanbase mm-hmm then you got you know
heart stones doing heart stones one of
the companies is doing really well so
what I want to ask is when it comes to
Activision - but Activision and Blizzard
do you think that you know with the
underperforming games what they're doing
one do you think that that's gonna
reflect how they do business at these
microtransactions I don't in - do you
think you know other companies are
secretly in this kind of you know
dilemma but they're not coming out
openly in saying first of looks like we
have one of our blizzard in World of
Warcraft representatives that has joined
us stream team lead Louis now although
what's going on sir yeah you don't
everybody happy new year how things
things are good I see you playing that
Wow every strong continuous climate
wrong it's very strong so does that look
like to me is I saw you do a raid I was
in there for about an hour to ask but I
was like they just look like bullet
sponges
but uh I think Lord Jets would
appreciate your wild love but uh tell me
what you think about what's going on man
acted this is a near and dear subject to
you so what do you feel about all this
news coming out so I've I've been saying
probably for over four years that
there's been a steady decline in the
background that nobody has seen on the
blizzard and Activision fighting in the
corporate level because you lost
medicine you you then lost to CEOs this
year you lost more hime
so you've lost all these executives from
the top of the blizzard structure these
core people that are now leaving and
this there's going to be like a huge
fracture right down the middle and
Activision is just throwing all of their
corporate executives into the blizzard
structure that is just going to pretty
much dissolve them from the inside out
because you've lost you've lost almost
all of love for heroes of the storm
which means you've lost the one cool
thing about it which is heroes of the
dorm that whole people of everyone
loving them I totally agree with what
accent about the love for overwatch 14
is pretty much destroyed them whoa
Starcraft is going to still stay alive
they're gonna still be around
there's like the number one sport in
Korea right are they really gonna take
that no now one of the other things we
got to think of is Diablo if ya saw the
they they made everyone so mad they
could've said very easily given a video
and gone hey guys listen we're going
mobile with Diablo but Diablo 4 is in
the works they let me do that which
shows they have no nothing but but no
love for them anymore so and then you
got the head or I should say the head
designer Ian Haase kosis talking about
blizzard we're talking about Warcraft
and you know what it looks like in every
single week he is doing damage control
and you know just by looking at his face
he's just like yeah I'm here because
they're making me
moving from the script like he under
duress if you watch him he just looks
like he's just like I've been beaten up
every day this week and I'm just hitting
everyone happy and everyone was just
gonna attack me because on pretty much
their poster boy let me finish cuz I'm
very curious you know obviously I know
he has some blizzard love going on here
but then I know he doesn't have any not
a lot of Activision law so every single
level everything the Activision I know I
wasn't a blogger when Activision joined
up with Blizzard or they merged or
whatever it was I mean it is he's
technically technically a merger but it
ain't really and I knew I knew even back
then in a take a while but that will
destroy Blizzard and you start saying
but you know it's uh I actually have
Blizzard sources and was forcing and you
know I don't I don't leak blizzard stuff
cuz it's not really what I'm known for
stuff like that but I I heard things
about da before and obviously I Kotaku
has done a ton of reporting on what's
going on Blizzard and you know they were
saying like finance finance executives
were sitting in on creative meetings
which is something that they had like
yeah you had like the two the two chief
financial officers of both of whom are
now gone they were sitting in on
creative meetings and being like oh well
why don't you do this it'll make more
money you know and that's that's
something that wasn't in Blizzard DNA
before you know anecdotally it does feel
like morale is low with with the people
are know from Blizzard but I have also
heard that you know what they do have
dabbler for is really promising and
there are
grand plans for it and as such I'm not
like I'm personally not worried about
that but like you can you can just you
can just feel how crappy and corporate
blizzards thigh becoming you know like
the fact that Balfour Azeroth was
probably the most rushed expansion to
market that I can remember I had my
admire your balls to continue playing
again that's why I was playing with
randoms and like I suppose like with
with wow it's who you play with that
really makes it especially when it's got
a crappy expansion like that but that
was seriously the system's have
implemented in in bar Fraser otha with
completely untested you know it's like
like I'm not gonna go into the big
details because I popped off the podcast
asleep put it this way they Pro the the
way that bar frazzle Roth works new
least it works at launch was like there
was like multiple layers of progression
called this azurite system or bar but
the the problem is obtaining this as a
right stuff was the most boring systems
they've ever put in the game in Ireland
expeditions and war fronts and and the
world quests are bad too and bands just
every feature every had one feature
about Francois was a complete failure
and feels like if they'd spend more time
tap but not only that the classes were
broken too well honey it's like it's not
like he's so much like they didn't test
it enough do you feel just that I'm
sorry I'm totally cutting out on you but
I feel like if they actually put some
time and some money into what they did
that player basis will be there because
it's almost like at least they should
have known this was coming because they
saw from warlords of draenor being so
like they've totally messed up well
those are draining work and then
just redid it again now well put it this
way right there's two there are two
teams that work on blizzard expansions
this is a B team expansion oh definitely
a team made Legion and Legion race was
like probably the best expansion ever
like port loads of players back I Eve I
came back after like being away from the
game for several years and I was like oh
my god this is so amazing the summer
stuff to do so much story and content
blah blah and going to bar Fraser off
they had like really good marketing and
there's all this controversy about the
story and what they're doing and it's
like oh it's got to be as good as Legion
and then it kind of sort of was not as
good and you've got all these stuff with
heroes of the storm I don't if you see
in this drama but then it basically
caught the heroes of the storm dev team
in half or more laid off a bunch of
people a few weeks before Christmas
cancelled all the eSports stuff all the
amps yeah all those guys are out of a
job that just reeks of Activision man I
can't I can't see Mike Morhaime
see thinking you know what let's put all
these guys out of work just before
Christmas I can't see him doing that
yeah they think the thing that seems
scary that you mentioned the first thing
I hear when you're talking about
Activision higher-ups sitting in on
creative meetings that concerns you know
yeah yeah it should be noted as well
well you mentioned that is that before
Activision and Blizzard had separate
CEOs Mike Morhaime was the CEO of
Blizzard what Bobby Kotick was the CEO
of Activision well no Jason Allard is
just the president of Blizzard he's not
the senior Blizzard so like however when
Blizzard gets a new chief financial
officer I won't be the CFO of Blizzard
it'll be like you know Director of
Finance at Blizzard and that Vale answer
to Activision CFO is I think they
actually got Xbox his old CFO anyway
yeah did you hear did you hear when they
finally announced half of the stuff at
Blizzcon that David Burak who is the X
Diablo the original Diablo
he was just like Activision Blizzard he
goes they
they just lost total touch of what the
people want they just they don't want
him anymore
well I heard that they were originally
gonna plan to show something of Daiya
blow three but like i mean that's what
that to do right and when they know when
they announced a blow [ __ ] they were
like don't you guys have phones or
whatever that people were just instantly
like well why didn't they do what they
did with gears and just say yeah guess
what
well like do what they did with
elderscrolls blades or whatever yes and
they're like yeah Elder Scrolls blades
we've got this mobile game but also for
Alice cross six coming and stuff like
that why didn't they just do that yeah I
agree
just seems like division corporatism is
they just gone completely out of touch
now let me let me get Randian on his
favorite uh publisher Activision oh what
rare would you hear about all this these
news in the franchise the state of their
franchise and stuff like that I mean
what do you watch it thaw process do you
do you think they're on the decline do
you think finally that the evil empire
might be showing ships in Arma i kind of
smile when they say but it's like I
don't think they I think they've just
they just like they're just not making
enough money for them you know yeah like
like I don't believe for a second
Destiny's not profitable right
Activision it's just like it didn't make
us to bill it made only made this
billion it didn't make us three billion
like we were on it or whatever they are
the word in my opinion like the worst
publisher out there by far some of these
like modern warfare for leaks are kind
of interesting ya know so I guess it's
not ghost that was career
but there are some other leaks and it's
modern warfare 4 and so it has a
campaign it's got blackout and all that
but the campaign isn't the new campaign
the campaign for modern warfare 4 is a
remastered modern warfare 2 and 3 which
sounds like the Activision thing
and then a new blackout map you know the
multiplayer and the zombies and all this
stuff and it's like I was reading that
stuff and I'm like this sounds like ok
so we're not doing a campaign again but
we're just gonna be master mountain
warfare 2 and 3 and say that's the
campaign like it totally Activision man
like I don't know that I don't like
Bobby Kotik room blizzard is a travesty
like a year ago blizzard and Bethesda
were like loved by everybody and a year
later they're like two of the most hated
companies for whatever reason now but
read slow-mo as he said but Activision
could it be possibly worse than EA
Activision is so much worse than the a
the flak right yeah doesn't actually
want to be hated they just dumb if
Activision had the same issue with the
loot boxes that EA did they would have
never reneged on it like it like they
know they hate they they're like let's
see how how evil we can be this way
selling a red dot for a red dot sight
for $3 I got a comb for you James
because you out here with their fallout
76 and if Christmas kids bra I was
defending that either I was talking to
someone earlier about this where like my
friend was like I don't know if I want
to I don't know if I want to buy the I
don't know if I want to buy the
expansions for The Witcher 3 because
they're they're kind of pricey and I was
like do you realize that the the price
of a Witcher 3 expansion cost the same
as a bunch of remotes and
on their way in one year rewriting their
whole culture as far as public
perception I just bought that funny but
I think they pioneered the DLC the whole
sama division actually do all they make
this Call of Duty right year after year
to slow most things like oh like EA is
least giving us dead space Mirror's Edge
but I think I think above and beyond
Activision Activision's nastiness I
think there's also an issue of stagnancy
within blizzards in terms of IP like you
cannot continue just to just rely on
Diablo and overwatch and you know what a
candy crush or what not to make my just
relied on halo gears and for when you
look at see Blizzard thing about
Blizzard is Blizzard this pairing was
always weird to me anyway because you
pair a company that prides itself on
taking a sweet time making its games
with a company that wants you to chuck
one out every single year that was
always gonna be an issue right but I
just think like when you look at what
other things that Blizzard has in his
portfolio like Starcraft Starcraft
like you can't just the desire for a
mass-market real-time RTS isn't there
anymore you're gonna have your fans
they're gonna love it but it's not gonna
appeal to the mass market the way an
Activision wanted to so it's like a is
Blizzard ever gonna be in a position
again to make a game that sort of
changes the rules like with overwatch
they sort of hit that right they hit
that where they gave you a hero shooter
that was accessible anybody could play
but if you if you want to go to shooting
you could be good at defending and then
they hit that market and that hit for a
while again and it's a matter of it how
much money is it making
yeah India but sob and you have to
understand with Activision what their
whole modus operandi is is margins
they're like how much money we can we
make by spending as little as possible
and that's why apparently we're getting
Modern Warfare 2 campaign with more
warfare whatever you know it's that it's
cutting corners coin corners are making
money without spending money and that's
why like Call of Duty basically reuses
flipped assets every single year people
still buy it
every single year and Activision want
that like low low cost high margin life
style for all of its games now the
problem with that is that's that's the
antithesis as well exactly
this it's all about polish it's all
about testing everything until it's done
that was that whole thing was like yeah
it'll come out when it's ready like they
wouldn't announce the word back and they
they wouldn't even announce when a well
expansion was coming out until like a
few weeks prior because they would wait
until it was genuinely ready whereas now
it's like about four Azeroth's
it's okay ish let's just push out the
door and pray to the fanbase make Jess
really sad are you guys okay with just
more Diablo more Warcraft
remember that overwatch was never there
baby you have to remember the project
Titan was there baby
they rioted and for overwatch and so
that was never originally theirs so they
ended up just picking it up so they were
just like oh that we just really liked
this so we think it's gonna be cool and
they bought it this thing is interesting
man I look at it and I'm like one Bungie
to get out of it yeah yeah
revered Bungie was before winning right
before this happened and they got over
there - evil Activision I didn't know
division was and I was so eager because
you know these are gonna do thing like
you know somebody a chance to do
anything and you see their real vision
right we saw some what parts of their
vision but then it started breaking down
like right before the game's release
story got revamped they fired a whole
bunch of people and whole-body disobey
Marty so dirty
terrible all types of bad things that
happened and then as I played the game
then I'm a destiny night hmm
I seen the flaws stuff that made sense
for them to do it's like it's direct
conflict did bungees having a direct
conflict with the boss activist and they
put in when they put in test Everett
y'all yes we know a little but I got
every see it is that the shop oh yeah
yeah I know about that when the money
when it was alright your chin time okay
y'all nice but we need this bread yes
when it turn to that and I was like
that's not bungees mo like bungees I'm
most totally different and I just want I
just want Bungie away from these guys
that's all I think they had a bad
relationship you know how you got your
friend she's in a better relationship
well he's in a bad relationship and you
just try to point out man you know
that's not a good relationship for you
you know you looking bad hanging out
that's like Cognito plane dust Oh
I understand the flaws of my
relationship I do feel like you spend
too much money on a PC not to use it too
oh well you know my PC is well the stuff
like the video editing and stuff like
that that's gonna happen so really yes
which I got a laptop there's probably
more mouths within a lot of people
species out there never ball with me to
eat really do work I'm with you I'm with
you of that King I bought a PC last year
you know it's got a it's got a 1080 in
it got a i seven seven seventy seven
hundred k like and I don't use it I only
use it for video editing you know yeah
it's I don't use it for gaming and you
know Randy looking in he's not excited
about that opportunity man like yeah I
started doing my reviews for games
uploading it in 4k so I can video and it
which takes like a ten minute video and
thirty like rendered at like 30
megabytes takes like half an hour on
this PC pretty good I said what a waste
of pcs which you got that's right so
long but I know the trap it's a huge
trap and Cognito doesn't know the trap
I'm so happy for him right now
right when the trap hit someone hey it's
gonna hit him
- is that because he's not a goal to
play a game and it's not gonna look like
that fresh car isn't that how the first
car smell sovereign those shoes it's
gotten better over the years but it's
still kind of the same light because
when once you start when you start
seeing like little differences and
things and you become I mean you're a
tech head to become nit picky and you're
like wait why is this this why can't I
get this better and then you start
looking up like peoples different
configurations and what they turn on
what they turn off and then you go down
that rabbit hole and that's all we don't
play game play hardware 80t eyes in here
running in whatever whatever they thing
is mom I think they changed it from SLI
I have a running in here right now I can
run godly games infrastructure and I get
a my you've got on a tangent on PC but
the thing what made it easier for me now
is discord I think like this Court is
like they're like almost a universal you
know I feel about this I know you hate
with a passion but it's where it's at
right now and that's the only thing
saving it but enough about PC we move on
on yeah I'm concerned with the
activision blizzard stuff I think the
King's just I don't know me his his his
line up ain't looking as dominant as it
used to I definitely see him and so we
shall see solvers wrap this thing up
with a we traded we traded in
super-selfish guy let's get this bad yes
so apparently we have a new challenger
in the
of hardware Slightly Mad Studios the
developer of the I would say highly
acclaimed well-regarded racing series
project cars have decided that apart
from project cars three then next
endeavor is going to be a game console
named the mad box console the console
should be coming out within the next
three years or so they spec it out to be
about as powerful as a pretty powerful
PC at that time so they're they're sort
of uh I guess they have a time machine
that tells them what its gonna be helped
off was gonna be in three years time um
they've already showed sort of uh
concepts of what the console is gonna
look like it looks kind of disgusting
but that's that's another thing I want
to know what you guys think of this I
mean I I'm of the mind that hey I will
never begrudge anybody trying to go in
and challenge the status quo and shake
things up
that's how Sony got into the business
that's how Microsoft got into the
business and that's how you know even
other failed endeavors like the video
you know they took this shot and you win
or you lose but you take your shot and I
think it's always good when somebody
wants to kind of stir the pot and change
things up I don't know what what what
what could come of this I'm still a long
ways off so hey it's interesting what we
know so let's frame this Oh for what we
know solve this guy what is it the end
Bell from yeah yeah the CEO here in his
arm he's claiming like they supposed to
have like a full engine to kind of
develop games for free so yeah so I
guess the whole the whole thing with the
platform is that they they feel that
specifically they said they say they
feel that exclusives are exclusionary
they don't want that so they want to
create a platform where they're not
holding anybody that's partnered with
them for putting games on a console too
not putting their games on other
consoles all so in addition to that they
plan to before the console ships out
they
do have some sort of proprietary sort of
engine that will help
I guess people scale are there games
across other platforms or all platforms
um that they plan to ship with the UH
with the console so that's it's sort of
cool like they were doing sort of what
epic is doing with their with their
storefront where they're giving people
the tools to sort of put games onto
their onto their platform so that's a
cool thing because they are a game
developer they have that expertise um
and that way that's another way to sort
of engender people to to your platform
um again I don't know beyond that he's
he specifically I know he got into a
back-and-forth with people on Twitter a
lot of times
yeah a lot of specs and claims that he
made about VR functionality and guess he
said something about well I've been told
that 120 frames per second is is very
smooth for VR meaning 60 frames per
second per eye and then people are
saying well if you want really high-end
stuff then you're gonna need more you
need about 180 frames per second when 95
second per eye so if there was a
back-and-forth and he admitted that he
doesn't have any sort of expertise and
this is what he's being told so I mean
and he's a funny dude cuz that he never
had a Twitter account personal until he
announced the mad box right and one of
the first things you see on the Twitter
account is like him on a yacht children
after so I'm wondering where all this
funding money is going for the
masquerade balls what ran is at that
point now there's a xbox have to change
your moniker I mean you know it where
the most powerful console but you know
we have to buy the man box I think the
likelihood of this console coming out is
slim to none and slim just left town I
honestly do not see this thing being
like I've heard phantoms coming we line
up for the fan
and it's like they make project cars and
now they're gonna cool next step you
make a console are they getting the
funding from this read you don't feel
that's the logical progression after
project I like it seems I don't know
like the render looks it looks like the
ugliest thing I've ever seen in my life
right it's nasty and you know what's
gonna happen jazz is gonna get on here
and be like well I've heard some
interesting news that this is real and
that it will be coming tell us about
your the mad box what do you know about
inside info about how it's gonna be my
no I saw it and just roll my eyes and
then put it into the part of my brain
where I instantly forget everything like
ah a guy a guy we've got a channel on
slack where we discuss you know things
were going to cover during the day and
higher up in my company was like can
someone write about this and like nobody
wanted to write about it and he was like
yeah fine I'll write about it and he
just wrote a really scathing guy call
about VR and like the technical stuff he
got wrong and stuff like that and I just
like it's just stupid NEC head
interprets our PC engine PC do all all
of that I missed that I was the outcast
when these dudes playing Sega and
Nintendo I had that stuff but um nothing
can top on my turbo duel I've been
looking for that turbo duel if this man
system guy can be that guy I'm all for
it I'm 100% in I will jump in one hunt
you need funding now uh what's up
because if you can get that feel
because remember turbo graphic said they
was really 16-bit wait really wasn't
there was going to have to eight bits
together and conjunction but it was
blazing and I'm just I'm just now I want
that lie under coming out party like you
want a mad box you're gonna be
celebrating it he should be proud of all
our games
he said the matte box selfies we receive
we get free games for life he said it's
gonna be a four car the specs are
incoming we aren't using old kit we're
in talks now to get the very best
available the thought of bringing out a
system you always go be as powerful as
the PC of that time right yeah yeah I
mean the trips my trip talk to you early
on you looked at him like he was God
like he was yeah and then you got the
product in your hand it was something
else but whatever no he pushed us
forward it gave us that push forward
what we don't like about chip Hawkins
was the m2 now position in his wallet
because he knew the downfall if this
system can come to to to the market
great I'm down with it I'm gonna buy it
I'm not gonna lie I'm gonna buy it
I'm gonna take my selfies for life
whatever they say know damn well this
system is in the bushes no let's say
he's down lid on Twitter I give them
that you don't Sam what I can't take
these I'm would rain I cannot take these
dudes serious until I see software how
are they gonna get the read
to get this to the masses that's the
next oh oh we know how much project
cause he made maybe he made such a
Bitcoin I'm kind of waiting like I'm
working and I'm whisking in the sense
that I want them I want to see what
happens whether they crash and burn is
another story I want to read save me
from all of this to see it come out like
I'm with be interesting but like come on
- and then like by the way guys we're
making we're digging the money to earn B
this stuff and then put it out and
that's what I said he never had a
Twitter account he opens it the day he
announces the console and the first
thing you see is him on a big yacht
popping bottles women around him like
way Holloway Lord Russell Holly had a
great article of this I'm with I'm with
Lord Russell Holly I think this thing is
nothing to be going mad about talking
about in China
yeah he's a good guy good guy he wrote a
fantastic article - on it and it just I
just can't see it man through and then
he's talking three years from now yeah
that's another thing so that that
council would like if you think about
it's probably coming out against the mid
gen refresh it's 2021 so he trying to
get us height now for 2021 I'm just come
on man
hi - and me putting out stuff some yo
some of the stuff that they put now you
like yeah but see you know what it is
systems in your house you playing them
listen remember when Microsoft said they
will be releasing the system and they
did it from the make so that sort of
intro line I was going to do like from
the makers of project cars gonna be like
we don't know its financial situation
the landscape the landscape of gaming if
you look at what's happening with epic
discs or like on a serious note the
landscape is changing we have like
honestly things could look vastly
different in five years you know
anything could happen anything if there
is actual real funding for this because
you said it's not being crowd for the
clashes and burns when we find out this
guy's Ponzi scheme in people he ends up
like whatever the case may be
I wanted to play out I want to see this
drama play out whatever it is Fido note
on the bad box people say I kinda I kind
of morbidly curious to see morbidly
cured that's you know disruption
competition is always great you know and
in anything flops and like people say
goes to jail then podcast remember that
time and it's like a soldier boy
situation
see a day it is it was soldier boy told
you no coming out with console you like
oh shut up his website forty bucks he
was selling for four hundred though yes
yeah until Nintendo stepped in and took
it all with compiling all of the latest
rumors regarding Microsoft's next-gen
approach with the scarlet family of
consoles do you think this multifaceted
console strategy will be too confusing
for the casual gamer the choices are a
yes 2013 all over again
Microsoft has not learned their lesson
with messaging be no the Xbox one X and
s prove gamers understand SKUs like cell
phones or C my anaconda don't want none
if he a guy please Rock the aisle people
when it goes up on Twitter Lords of the
Xbox to read out orange escorted an
absolute pleasure to have you in the
realm of glow Awards where can I find
people find you and what do you have
going on well thank you guys so much for
having me Murtagh neato Bing sovereign
thanks for having me on I love I love
being on the show love listen to you
guys unfortunately a little bit early
for me so I usually have to catch it on
demand but uh you know you can check me
out on youtube Randall for 19 well the
relative links will be there you know
Twitter all that good stuff
I mean jazz shall be returning to the
realm of podcasting hopefully sometime
this week
I don't know maybe we shouldn't we just
did a podcast maybe we just take another
week off good absolute pleasure man
looking forward to the next video you
got coming on I'm hoping it'll be soon
man it's always fantastic high quality
work Lord jazz man what do you got going
on in wicked if I'm fine
I can find me on Twitter I just Gordon
jay-z said CID in where I post loads of
crap
so probably don't follow me I am Ryan I
khals
would you okay I guess other than that
thanks Rodney guys this podcast is it's
always a lot of fun dude I really
appreciate thank you play video games
and with the public service announcement
show you guys one of my favorite
podcasts love the chemistry great
combination always informative always
hilarious you doing what you to do and
again thank you both for coming on
together and absolute honor man I love
you guys big-time so Lord addict had to
go so uh Lord soft what can the fine
people find you in 2019 hopefully online
playing but here come on you'll see me
the game that I got so del V wolfish
visited 2019 I promise all right that's
what you gonna wicked people find you
man
oh it's a vile P on Twitter and BX
sovereign on PSN and Xbox Live a big
shout out to jazz and ran you guys are
hilarious I love it when when cog said
you guys leading the year over layoffs
man I gotta be awake let's go dragon
today we got to set it off right with
the best absolutely
King these great shoes in the background
bro
you see the dolly right there another
table from Ikea that's the presenting
table so we very high quality guys that
I look forward to his Ram dealer and
Colt soul if my quality is not up to
snuff I will keep working until he gets
there Oh combat
yes we got Pacquiao be the first combat
talk with the king this year it's going
to be ridiculous because I am so into
this fight coming up and for giving us
the best we can quickly if I talk
lioness let's go yeah we'd talk about
maids Joe Fonzarelli Nino we were
supposed to do that car and it wasn't
and now how're we supposed to do it um
we will pick another car to do Oh combat
talk podcast but I wanted to have that
friend barroom fill when we watch in a
fight we reacting alive and you're
seeing us when we're talking and we're
communicating I want a real serious
podcast to deal with a real serious card
agreed agreed and we would do it man
shot the Fonz who working with cooking
up something yes and he'll get that Luke
chase radio feel you know what I'm
talking about yes
oh yeah man will do that man again you
know here man fantastic show a lot of
last chat with app made thanks for the
super chat guys it's our first super
chats absolutely amazing
almond and again salute for the 1000 you
guys helping us out on that Lord kibosh
was gonna get all the audio up on
Spotify iTunes all that good stuff also
shout him later and flashpoint with Eve
artists is under construction so we're
gonna gave you the new name just guys
what show no guys pick a name yet did
you pick a man I'm not allowed to talk
about it it's not gonna be that it is
the others like two guys one destiny I'm
like no I bought this man yo eating law
he's popping bottles right now my
brother he just hit 30,000 subs like so
the screen he's one of the best in the
game so I'm hopefully his agent contact
my agent so I can tell you the name when
I'm allowed tell it it a shot the PD who
came through obviously of the selfish
pretty only one so about why all day and
he's the leader of our string team a man
does a fantastic job and I absolutely
want to salute him but yeah that's all
we got man Lord's everybody anything
else to see will get everyone out of
here man everybody enjoy your Sunday and
peace later